le département et antenn Réunion vous
présente lien
[Musique]
social l'agriculture biologique garantit
des aliments sans engrais ni pesticides
chimiques mais ce mode de culture est
plus subti et plus contraignant pour
palier les difficultés des exploitations
bio le département propose des revalor
d'aide et des subventions spécifiques
aux besoins des agriculteurs Pascal
dijou a repris l'exploitation de son
père à la Plaine des Cafres pour
transformer ses parcelles en culture
biologique il a dû moderniser son
terrain et repartir de
[Musique]
zéro on retrouve donc la reine des
glaces qui est une salade croquante on
retrouve aussi également donc des
Batavia blonde de la feuille de chaîne
rouge des salades mais aussi des choux
des poireaux des pommes de terre et tout
est bio Pascal a repris l'exploitation
familiale en 2009 son père aujourd'hui à
la retraite faisait dans l'agriculture
conventionnelle à base d'engré et de
pesticides Pascal lui a choisi
l'agriculture biologique j'aime bien
savoir ce que je mange je quand je mange
je le mange avec plaisir et puis et puis
en sachant qu' il y a il il y a pas de
pesticide dessus on a beaucoup de
problèmes de pollution actuellement que
ce soit au niveau des navesatiques des
problèmes de santé cancer diabète et
tout ça et tout ça ça nous amène à nous
questionner sur notre mode
d'alimentation et je me dis ben bien
s'alimenter c'est bien prévenir aussi sa
santé contrairement à l'agriculture
conventionnelle très monoculture Pascal
diversifie sa production toute l'année
il réfléchit à ce qu'il va planter pour
ne pas que le sol s'appauvrisse la
rotation des cultures est un pilier de
l'agriculture biologique la difficulté
trouver le bon équilibre par exemple on
fait une culture qui est gourmande à la
suite dans dans le plan de rotation on
va mettre une plante moins gourmande
comme des légumesfeuilles que ce soit
donc des breides ou des choses comme ça
des radis ça va permettre aussi au sol
de se reposer et après dans la rotation
on va laisser aussi dans le courant de
l'année on va laisser le sol se reposer
on va le mettre en jacher on va planter
des des plantes qui vont laisser le sol
se reposer en se décomposant il a fallu
2 ans d'effort et de la beur pour
reconvertir les terres de son père
aujourd'hui Pascal est labélisé AB
agriculture biologique pour pour
moderniser son terrain l'agriculteur a
bénéficié de subvention de l'Europe et
du département à hauteur de 60 %. c'est
des aides qui sont très important
surtout pour pour des jeunes
agriculteurs ou des jeunes agriculteurs
qui qui se lancent et qui ont pas donc
forcément donc de de de trésoreries ils
ont pas de moyen de de construire ça et
donc c'est vrai que c'est c'est une aide
pour nous lancer qui qui est impératif
sans ces aid c'est possible mais c'est
toujours du bidouage c'est toujours du
système D ces AES nous permet donc de de
de nous lancer et d'avoir une situation
une situation stable cette aide va
permettre à Pascal de mécaniser son
exploitation d'améliorer son réseau
d'irrigation de créer un verger et
d'installer des seres ces aides
départementales sont communes à tous les
agriculteurs mais sont revalorisés pour
les exploitations biologiques conscient
qu'il faut faire un effort
supplémentaire en direction des
agriculteurs qui travail dans
l'agriculture biologique nous avons
accordé avec l'Europe et la contrepartie
nationale le départ
un bonus supplémentaire en direction de
ces agriculteurs pour les encourager
dans leur modernisation dans le
développement de leur exploitation nous
sommes maintenant rentrés dans une
véritable dynamique agricole à la
Réunion et grâce au programme européen
qui est aujourd'hui activé nous allons
pouvoir accompagner nos agriculteurs
jusqu'en 2020- 2022 Pascal produit
environ 400 kg de fruits et légumes par
semaine 80 % de sa production est
écoulée sur le marché forain de
Saint-Pierre le reste revendu au GAB le
groupement des agriculteurs biologiques
de la Réunion cette structure fédère et
accompagne les acteurs du bio dans leur
démarche on est en partenariat avec le
département qui qui nous soutient dans
notre démarche pour développer et
promouvoir l'agriculture biologique et
au niveau des agriculteurs je fais aussi
le lien d'informer les agriculteurs de
toutes les aides qui sont proposé par le
département et qui malheureusement ne
sont pas forcément bien connu pour que
les produits biologiques passe
directement des champs à l'assiette un
projet est en cours avec les cantines
scolaires c'est un un gros projet de
livrer la restauration collective qui
est orienté aussi par le ministère de
l'Agriculture et soutenu par le
Département localement hein et du coup
ce qu'on est en train de construire avec
les directeurs et les chefs de cantine
c'est comment amener le bio à l'assiette
de nos enfants l'agriculture biologique
se développe de plus en plus à la
réunion entre 2008 et 2014 le nombre
d'exploitations certifié bio a triplé
Pascal lui souhaite que cette méthode se
transmette ce que je voudrais c'est que
la personne qui va le reprendre et ben
elle va continuer à travailler dans le
même sens que moi c'est-à-dire donc
d'essayer de la
diversifier le plus possible avec et
trouver de recréer un écosystème où tout
où le vivant est placé en
premier il faut véritablement créer
cette dynamique créer cet engouement et
montrer que l'agriculture biologique
peut-être une agriculture saine à
condition qu'elle soit suivie et qu'elle
soit accompagnée il s'agit pas de faire
du
biologique il s'agit de faire de
l'agriculture
[Musique]
biologique cofinanceur avec l'Europe le
département propose plusieurs types
d'aide aux agriculteurs bio une
bonification des aides déjà existantes
pour la création ou la modernisation
d'infrastructure la mécanisation et
l'équipement des exploitations la
gestion fouragère en production animal
et le développement des petites
exploitations il existe aussi une mesure
spécifique d'aide à l'agric biologique
elle est calculée en euros par hectare
par an accordée pour 5 ans et vise à la
conversion et au maintien de
l'exploitation biologique pour plus
d'information vous pouvez vous adresser
à la Direction de l'Agriculture de l'eau
et de l'environnement situé 26 avenue de
la victoire à Saint-Denis ou vous rendre
sur le site du département au
[Musique]
www.cg974.fr